Good evening, sir.
I'm a lecturer by profession and also
research scholar in Islam and
comparative studies. May I know your
name, please? I'm Nilima.
I respect your great enlightenment, sir,
but I have a small qualification to be
made. Like let us go back to the
Bhavishya Purana part three, Khanda
three, Adhyay three, and shlokas five to
eight.
Before going to this, I would just like
to mention that maybe you already know
because every prophet who comes in the
name of God will fulfill the prophecy
which is made for him. So, any prophet
who fulfills 50% of that prophecy is not
qualified to be a prophet. I mean, this
is a simple logical thing. So, now
coming back to the Bhavishya Purana, you
talked about the Mleccha leader saying
that he's none other than Muhammad.
Okay. Now, I accept the first half of
the thing of the shloka you said, but
the second 50% which is still ignored.
Now, sir, let me tell you Mleccha, the
word meaning Mleccha, it is derived from
Sanskrit dictionary. I mean, the
meaning. And the meaning means non-Aryan
or sinner or wicked person. These are
the three different meanings given to
the word Mleccha. So, according to this,
can Muhammad be a sinner or a wicked
person? The second part is the second
condition of the prophecy is that he
will belong to Marusthal and in
Sanskrit, land of death. Because Maru I
mean, it is derived from Sanskriti Mru.
Mru is death. And
definitely it does not quoting to the
land of Arabia because it is a barren
land or it is a battlefield. And next,
coming to the third point of faith, this
prophecy also mentions that that Mleccha
leader will take bath in Panchagavya and
in river Ganges. And it is a common
truth, we know that Ganges means Ganga
river and we all know that Ganga is not
in Arabia, but it is in India. It is a
universal fact. And coming to the taking
bath in Panchagavya, the meaning of
Panchagavya is five products of cow. And
the products of cow is milk, curds,
ghee, urine, cow dung. And now, sir,
coming to this part exclusively,
this prophecy must be fulfilled
by Muhammad, wherein if you show me at
least single reference from Quran
wherein Muhammad has taken bath in
either
in all these five products, that is
milk, curds, ghee, urine, and cow dung,
I'm ready to accept Islam today. Thank
you, sir. Sister has rightly said
that if the prophecy that we give, if
more than 50% is not fulfilled, then the
prophecy is wrong. I agree with you,
sister.
I agree with you.
And I will answer all your three
queries.
Let's see whether you accept Islam or
not today.
That's a different thing that you may
not agree with the truth.
I will speak to you. I agree with you.
Mleccha, I agree with you all your three
definitions. Mleccha, one of the meaning
is non-Aryan, meaning a foreigner. One
of the meaning is sinner, one is a
wicked person. That's the reason like
the Hindus, they call the Muslims as
Mleccha. When they say that, they mean
actually wicked and sinner. But the
other meaning is also foreigner. As far
as when I speak, when I quote from any
scripture,
while quoting and while taking the
meaning, it's not necessary that if the
word has got four meanings, then more
than two meanings should be correct. No.
Even if one is correct, the meaning is
right. For example, the Quran says that
don't have pig.
Today, if you open the dictionary, one
of the slang meanings for pig is a cop.
Means a policeman. So, one meaning is
pig.
The other meaning is a policeman. But
naturally, the Quran and the Bible and
the Bible says in the book of Leviticus
chapter number 11 verse number 7 and 8
and the book of Deuteronomy chapter
number 14 verse number 8 and the book of
Isaiah chapter number 65 verse number 2
and 5,
when it says don't have pig, it doesn't
mean don't have a policeman.
If you are a student of comparative
religion, if there are 10 meanings, even
if one is correct, you have to choose
the right one.
Two may be correct, three may be
correct, all 10 may be correct, but even
if one is correct out of 10, it can
fulfill the prophecy.
So, here I agree with you, sister
Mleccha does mean non-Aryan. To Indian,
it will be a foreigner. And I said in my
speech when I translated, a Mleccha
means a foreigner.
Now, you want to go in the wrong way and
say Mleccha means wicked here, that is a
misunderstanding, sister.
If you say the Bible says and the Quran
says don't have a policeman, that means
you're not a student of comparative
religion, you are a novice.
If any one of the meanings fulfill the
prophecy,
one more thing, if there's a doubt,
there are 10 points that I mentioned.
All the others can't be refuted. Your
second meaning, Marusthal. One of the
Marusthal, I do agree. Mar means death,
but the other meaning of Marusthal in
Sanskrit is a sandy track. You go back
to the dictionary today and open. In our
Islamic Research Foundation, we have a
Sanskrit dictionary also, sister.
I am a student of comparative religion.
I do agree, one is a place of death, the
other is a sandy track. So, why are you
taking the wrong meaning?
That means you're going out of the way.
So, if you see the permutation and
combination, all the other points that I
mentioned are 100% correct. Here also,
you have to choose the right meaning.
So, one of the meanings of Marusthal
means a sandy track or a desert.
Coming to your third question.
And you're accepting Islam, inshallah.
Your third question that I mentioned in
the prophecy that Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam took a bath
in the Panch Garb in the Ganges.
Now, here we analyze that when we say in
the Hindu terminology, when you say bath
in the Panch Garb in the Ganges, it
means to purify.
One means actually you dip yourself in
the Ganges,
which I don't expect the prophet came
and dipped himself in the Ganges. It
means to purify. I did not give the
explanation because the lecture is very
long. I can speak on this topic for the
full day.
I did not give details of everything. I
can speak on each prophecy for another
few minutes, even for hours together.
So, here having a bath in the Panch Garb
means purify.
So, depending upon the context, it
doesn't mean a physical bath.
And even if you physically have a bath
in the Panch Garb in the Ganges, not
necessary you'll be purified. It is the
philosophy of the Hinduism. So, here
when the prophecy says that Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, had a bath
in the Panch Garb, it doesn't mean he
came here in the Ganges. It means that
he was purified by Almighty God. And we
believe that all the prophets of God,
all, whether it be Moses, Jesus Christ,
peace be upon them, and Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, all of them
were masoom. They were innocent. They
were pure. So, all the prophets of God,
of Almighty God which he sent down, all
of them we consider to be innocent, to
be masoom, to be pure. So, this answers
the question, and I hope inshallah
you'll accept Islam, sister.
Now, question from the mic on my left
hand side.
My name is Prem Advani. I am from New
Delhi, a retired senior citizen,
non-Muslim. My question is that Islam
with a glorious past should continue to
be more glorious with a present time.
I wish that the Muslims should give more
transparency and access to what
activities are being conducted from the
grassroot level of madrasahs and masjids
and so on, so that the people should
feel what is going on. The truth should
be transparent. My My name is
transparency. Thank you. Brother asked a
very good question. Before you answer
the question, I would just like to throw
some light. The sister had asked earlier
question three questions. And that
reminds me that my daughter who had come
last,
she had said a song,
"Don't talk to me about Muhammad." You
know,
peace be upon him. And
the coordinator said, "Please pay
attention to the words what he's
saying." And if you heard the words
carefully, it's the seerah of Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
that once Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam was going, he finds a companion
as a stranger. She starts speaking
against the prophet. "Oh, the prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam is a
bad person. Don't talk to me." She's
telling Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam that person doesn't know the
person he's talking to. She tells to the
stranger,
that person on the road, "That prophet
Muhammad is bad. Don't listen to him. He
causes disharmony. He teaches only about
one God, blah blah blah." That's what my
daughter was saying in that song.
Later on, but she says, "Oh, you're a
very good person. But I'm warning you,
don't listen to that man, Muhammad."
Peace be upon him.
"He's a rogue."
Na'uzubillah.
"He's a very bad person." Na'uzubillah.
And so on and so forth. But she says,
"You're a very good person. You're so
kind. You're so loving. Please, may I
know your name?"
Then she says, "Pardon?
What did you say?
Am I hearing correct?
Your name is Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam? Then she said, Ashhadu Alla
Ilaha Illallah wa ashhadu anna
Muhammadan Rasulullah.
So, when the traveler realizes that this
person is actually Prophet Muhammad,
peace be upon him, I've heard from other
people that he's the wrong person. This
person is so good. She immediately
accepts Islam.
So, our dear sister,
when she posed so many questions again,
I thought it reminds me of my daughter
when she was narrating the seerah of the
prophet in that song. The person, the
traveler attacking
Islam, attacking the Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. But when she
comes to know the truth, she says the
shahada. So, inshallah, our dear sister
also will say the shahada.
And I really ask Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
to open her heart.
Our dear brother here asked a very good
question.
He agrees that Islam had a glorious
past, but he says that there should be
transparency,
especially in the madrasa.
Who says no? I'm for you, brother.
I'm fully for you. Who says there should
be no transparency? Not transparency. I
want the non-Muslims to come and study
in this madrasa.
I'm aware, brother. I'm aware what
you're talking about the media. That the
media is saying that madrasas are
the schools of terrorism.
Media says, not you, brother. Media.
Madrasa in Arabic means a place of dars,
somewhat like a university.
You can call it a school, call it a
college, or call it a university.
But the media portrays as though, you
know, if you go to a madrasa,
you'll become a terrorist. Media
portrays, not you.
I'm asking number one person who has
killed maximum human beings in the world
is Hitler. Which madrasa did he go to?
Which madrasa?
Which madrasa he went to?
See, today, you know mafia,
the top people in the world from Italy
and all these smugglers, if you take a
survey
that all the smugglers, all the top
people that go to the jail, if you take
a survey, how many people go to madrasa?
How many? A small maybe maybe a couple
of percent. Majority go to universities.
Which university? Modern university,
schools, colleges.
So, can I say that we should close the
school? Can I say close the college of
education? Close BA, close BCom, close
BSc? No.
Because I know I have studied in the
school. That school doesn't say that you
should drop or you should smuggle. You
should go against the country. It is
they study in that school, but they are
the black sheep of that school.
So, Hitler also may have gone to the
modern education. I'm sure that the
school he went to didn't teach him that
he should kill 6 million Jews.
So, what we realize that these are black
sheep. So, as a whole,
you know, every year in this country
there are thousands of people who are
passing from madrasas, from Nadwa, from
Deoband, thousands of them. But, do you
say that they're going and killing
people? Not at all. It is the media
which portrays.
And now the government wants to go
and last year or year before last, they
went to Nadwa, imagine. They went to
Nadwa and they wanted to search what
they took out to check. To check what?
And Ali Mian Nadwi
Raimullah
He said, "Okay, come forward, check."
What they found? Nothing.
See, once in a blue moon,
one in a lakh,
one in a hundred thousand, one in a
million, maybe a person after they pass
the madrasa may have been misled. That
doesn't mean madrasa teaches that. But,
a bigger percentage of the students
studying from schools, modern education,
from colleges, from university
which we get degrees of BA, BCom,
engineering, doctor, more of the people
doing wrong activities than evil
activities. So, as far as transparency,
brother, I'm for it.
No madrasa will ever say that you do not
come and check. Our syllabus is open.
Even our school
in our school, we are teaching,
mashallah, we are teaching comparative
studies.
My student
from my school
knows more about Hinduism than average
Hindu.
He knows more about Christianity than
average Christian.
He knows more about Islam than average
Muslim because we pay attention to both
of them. So, as far as transparency,
brother, is concerned, I'm for you. I'm
with you.
And no one will ever say that you don't
come and analyze. Come, but don't blame.
Don't come with a negative mind. Come
with an open mind. You may never know
you may get hidayah.
You may come to the truth. Yes, brother.
Create an atmosphere of encouragement
for non-Muslims to come and learn
something and see for themselves.
That is what I mean by transparency so
that people should not have suspicion
that something wrong is going on.
Something good is going on. But you
should make it transparent.
Brother asked a very good question. We
should make it transparent for
non-Muslim come and study. Brother,
first invitation I give to you and your
children, come to IRF. I give invitation
to you.
See, Islamic Research Foundation has a
library.
It is one of the most well-equipped
libraries, at least in India, of
scriptures of different religions.
You know, we have more than 200
different types of Bible, more than 50
versions of the Bible. We have more than
50 translations only of Bhagavad Gita.
We have several translations of Vedas,
of Rigveda, Yajurveda, Atharvaveda. You
may not find in the library of your
government. You may not find in the
library of maybe your school of thought.
We encourage study and come to the truth
and leave aside others. I give the first
invitation to you and to your children.
I will even bear the air ticket
free.
Come to IRF
and we welcome you. Study, and we will
learn the truth together, inshallah.
Can you on the microphone? Yes, brother.
I wish to thank you
that you have taken my suggestion in the
right spirit, and I will take
opportunity to avail of your offer.
Please. Just write to us. I'll send you
an air ticket, inshallah.
Yes, brother from the center mic. My
name is Ramakrishna.
I'm a physiotherapy student.
My question is,
what is the need of Allah to create Adam
and and Eve and this total universe?
What he will get from this?
And my second question is, everything is
created by someone.
So, even God must have been created by
someone. What is the meaning of Allah?
Brother has three questions. The first
question is, why did God create Adam and
Eve, and what was his reason to create
all this world and humankind?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created Adam
and Eve, may peace be upon them both,
so that the humankind could come. They
were the great great grandparents. Allah
says in Surah Hujurat, chapter number
49, verse number 13, "Ya ayyuha n-nasu
inna khalaqnakum min dhakarin wa untha
wa ja'alnakum shu'uban wa qaba'ila li
ta'arafu. Inna akramakum 'indallahi
atqakum. Innallaha 'alimun khabir." Oh
humankind, we have created you from a
single pair of male and female, and have
divided you into nations and tribes, so
that you may recognize each other, not
that you may dis- spice each other. And
the most honored in the sight of
almighty God is the person who has
taqwa. The criteria to judge
any human being, it is not wealth, it's
not color, it's not caste, it's not
creed, it is taqwa, it is God
consciousness, it is righteousness, it
is piety. So, Adam and Eve, peace be
upon them both, they were our great
great grandparents, of yours also and of
mine also, all humankind.
Therefore, I call you a brother. We are
brothers in humanity.
Allah says you are not all mankind. And
Allah says in Surah Isra chapter number
17, verse number 70, "We have honored
the children of Adam." Almighty God has
honored all the children of Adam.
Whether they are born in India, USA, UK,
born in a Hindu family, or a Muslim
family, or a Christian family, Allah
says he has honored all the children of
Adam. If you are a human being, Allah
has honored you. Whether your name is
Zakir, Abdullah, Ramu, Shankar. If you
are born a human being, Allah has
honored you. Now coming to the question,
why has Almighty God created the human
beings?
Allah has created the human beings
because Allah says this is one of his
best creation.
All the other creations of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, they obey him.
We have the angels. Whatever Almighty
God says, the angels obey him directly.
They have no free will. The human beings
are the creation of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala which has a free will. We can
either obey him or disobey him. So Allah
has created such a creation. We are one
of his best creation. And the best of
forms. But we have a choice of either
obeying God or disobeying God.
If you obey God,
we will go to Jannah. We'll go to Swarg.
We'll go to heaven. If you disobey him,
we'll go to hell.
We'll go to Nark.
So this is a test for the hereafter.
Allah says in Surah Mulk chapter number
67, verse number two, "It is Allah who
has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds." So this life is a test for the
hereafter. So Allah has created the
human beings and Allah says in Surah
Dariyat chapter number 51, verse number
56, "That we have created the jinn and
the men
not but to worship him." So we are
supposed to worship, obey the
commandment of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So this is the different
creation of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
which has a free will of even going
against Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or
obeying him. All the other things, the
stars, the trees, the mountains, the
Quran says they do such that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala they prostate to him,
they obey him. We have a free will. Now
when Allah has given a free will, with
the free will if you obey him, we become
higher than the angels.
With the free will if you disobey him,
we become the partners of the devil. So
he's created us for the test for the
hereafter. Coming to your second
question, everything
has a creator who created
God.
If anyone says everything has a creator,
it is a wrong statement.
Every created thing has a creator.
The definition of God is he is
uncreated.
The moment you say who created God, he's
not God.
The definition of God is he is
uncreated. Suppose
a person comes and asks you
that brother,
my friend John,
he was admitted in the hospital. He gave
birth to a child. Can you guess was it a
girl or a boy?
Can you guess?
Try it out. Guess.
Can't guess. Why?
Can you on the microphone?
Can you guess was it a girl or a boy?
Huh?
See brother John,
he was admitted in the hospital.
He gave birth to a child. Was it a girl
or a boy?
Can you guess?
A 50 50% chance?
Girl or boy?
People are laughing. Why?
Can you guess?
Can't guess. Why?
Even if you guess, can you get the
answer right?
Okay, can you guess? I'll give you two
chances. Was it a girl or a boy?
Try and out. Girl. Girl.
Brother, can a man give birth to a
child?
Ah.
There you made a mistake.
Same way you made a mistake by asking
who created God.
A man cannot give birth to a child. So,
where's the question of it being a girl
or a boy? See, now you understood.
Ah, now that's good, brother. So, it was
a man cannot give birth to a child. So,
where's the question of a girl or a boy?
So, when you're asking me who created
God, God by definition, Allah by
definition is uncreated. The moment you
say who created Allah, he's not Allah.
Walam yakun lahu kufuwan ahad. There's
nothing like him.
Coming to your last
part of the question. Who is Allah?
Who's Allah?
The best definition I can give you is
quoted in Surah Ikhlas.
Chapter number 112, verse number 1 to 4.
It's mentioned in the Quran. Qul hu
Allahu Ahad. Say he is Allah, one and
only. Allahus Samad. Allah, the
absolutely eternal. Lam yalid wa lam
yulad. He begets not, nor is he
begotten. Walam yakun lahu kufuwan ahad.
There's nothing like him. This is a
four-line definition of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. Any human being, any person says
so-and-so candidate is God, if that
candidate fits in this four-line
definition, we Muslims have got no
objection in accepting that candidate as
God.
Four-line definition. This is a litmus
test for theology, for the study of God.
First is Qul hu Allahu Ahad. Say he is
Allah, one and only.
Allahus Samad. Allah, the absolutely
eternal. Lam yalid wa lam yulad. He
begets not, nor is he begotten. Walam
yakun lahu kufuwan ahad. There's nothing
like him. If you go to the Hindu
scriptures, the same is mentioned in the
Hindu scriptures.
Qul hu Allahu Ahad is mentioned if you
read Chandogya Upanishad, chapter number
six, section number two, verse number
one. Ekam Evadvitiyam. God is only one
without a second.
Second test. Allahus Samad. Allah, the
absolutely eternal. Bhagavad Gita,
chapter number 10, verse number three
says, "I am known as the lord of all the
worlds, unbegotten, the beginningless."
Third test. Lam yalid wa lam yulad. He
begets not, nor is he begotten. It's
mentioned in the Shvetashvatara
Upanishad, chapter number six, verse
number nine. Not just he
janita nacha deepa. Of him, there are no
lords. He has got no parents. Almighty
God has got no father. He has got no
mother.
And walam yakun lahu kufuwan ahad,
there's nothing like him, is mentioned
in Shvetashvatara Upanishad, chapter
number four, verse number 19. And
Yajurveda, chapter number 32, verse
number three, where it says, na tasya
pratima asti. Of that God, there is no
pratima, there is no idol, there is no
image, there is no photograph, there's
no sculpture. Who says that? Yajurveda,
chapter number 32, verse number three.
Same as walam yakun lahu kufuwan ahad.
So, any person saying so-and-so
candidate is God, if that candidate fits
in this four-line definition, we Muslims
have got no objection in accepting that
candidate as God. For example, some
people say, Bhagwan Rajneesh is almighty
God.
Once during question-answer time, a
Hindu told me, "We don't believe Bhagwan
Rajneesh is to be God." I never said
that the Hindus believe Bhagwan Rajneesh
is God. I said, "Some people believe
Bhagwan Rajneesh is to be God. Let us
put this Rajneesh to test." First test
is, qul huwallahu ahad, say he is Allah,
one and only. Was Rajneesh one and only?
Was he the only man who claimed
divinity? There are hundreds of them.
And in this country, we have thousands
of men who have claimed divinity. He's
not the only one.
But Rajneesh bhaktis say, "No, no, he's
unique." Let's go to the next test.
Allahus Samad.
Allah, the absolute and eternal. Was
Rajneesh absolute and eternal?
We know from his biography, from his
autobiography, he was suffering from
asthma, from diabetes, from chronic
backache. Imagine almighty God suffering
from asthma, diabetes, chronic backache.
Third test, lam yalid walam yulad. He
begets not, nor is begotten.
Bhagwan Rajneesh was born in Madhya
Pradesh. He had a father and mother. In
1981,
he goes to America, USA.
And he takes thousands of Americans for
a ride. In in of Oregon, he starts his
center and calls it as Rajneeshpuram,
his village.
Later on, the American government arrest
him and put him behind bar. Rajneesh
says, "The American government slow
poisoned me." Imagine almighty God being
slow poisoned.
In 1985, the American government kick
him out of the country. He comes back to
India in the same city, Poona, and he
goes back to his center, which is now
called as Osho commune. And if you go to
the samadhi
of Rajneesh, it is mentioned there on
the samadhi,
Bhagwan Rajneesh, Osho, never born,
never died, but visited the earth from
the 11th of December, 1931 to the 19th
of January, 1990.
Never born, never died, but visited the
earth from the
11th of December,
1931 to the 19th of January, 1990. They
forgot to mention in his samadhi, he was
not given visas to 21 countries of the
world.
Almighty God coming in this
world to visit the world and requires
visas to go to different countries.
And the Archbishop of Greece said, "If
you don't remove Rajneesh out of this
country, we'll burn his house and the
house of his disciples." And the last
test,
it's so stringent that no one besides
the true almighty God can pass. The
moment you can compare God to anything,
he's not God. Walam yakul lahu kufuwan
ahad. We know Rajneesh
like the human beings had a beard, one
nose, two eyes, two ears, two hands. The
moment you can compare God to anything
in this world, he's not God. Walam yakul
lahu kufuwan ahad. If someone says,
"Almighty God is thousand times as
stronger than Arnold Schwarzenegger."
You might have heard the name of Arnold
Schwarzenegger.
Have you heard Arnold Schwarzenegger?
The person who got the title Mr. World,
Mr. Universe,
the strongest man in the world, the
strongest man in the universe. The
moment you can compare God to anyone,
whether it be Arnold Schwarzenegger,
whether it be Dara Singh, whether it be
King Kong, whether it be a thousand
times or a million times, the moment you
can compare God to anything in this
world, he's not God. Well,
there's nothing like him. So, this is a
four-line definition of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala given in the Quran. Whichever God
you're worshipping, brother, put that
God to the test of Surah Ikhlas. If that
God passes,
that is the true God, otherwise it's a
fake God.
Let us have a question from the sisters'
side, please.
A non-Muslim sister should come forward
and ask a question, please.
Sister has a question that she lives
with a Muslim for several years. When I
said that all the religions speak good
things, then why do the Muslims ask me
to accept Islam? Point number one, I say
that all the religions, most of the
things they say are good, but Islam,
besides speaking good things, shows you
a way how to achieve that goodness.
And I give the example, all religions
say don't rob. Islam says the same, but
Islam shows you a way how to achieve a
state in which people will not rob. Give
zakat, give charity, after that someone
robs, chop off the hand.
There will be no robbery, there'll be no
crime. So, in this way I tried to
explain that
Islam, besides talking about good
things, shows you a way how to achieve
that state of goodness.
Secondly,
if I have to say, being a student of
comparative religion, if you have to
follow your Hindu scriptures, assuming
you're a Hindu,
if you have to follow your Hindu
scriptures,
if you have to be a good Hindu, your
Hindu scriptures say
there is one God.
I quoted all these verses in my previous
answer. One God.
Your scripture says don't do idol
worship. Bhagavad Gita chapter number 7
verse number 20. All those intelligences
have been stolen by material desires,
they worship demi gods, they do idol
worship.
You have to believe in one God.
I said in my lecture today that you have
to believe in the Antim Rishi.
The Kalki Avatar whose father's name
will be Vishnu Yash Abdullah. Mother's
name shall be Sumati Amina. Who will be
born in the village of Sambhala Mecca.
Who will be born with the chief of the
village of Sambhala chief of Mecca. He
will be a messenger for the whole of
humankind. He will get enlightenment at
night in a cave. He will go northwards
and come back. He will be given eight
qualities. He will be a messenger for
the whole of humankind. He will ride a
horse. He will have a sword in the right
hand. He will have four companions. He
will be helped by the angels and devtas.
On and on and on. Who is this person? If
you are a good Hindu
you have to believe in this Antim Rishi,
otherwise you're not a good Hindu.
If you are a good Hindu, you have to
believe in one God.
You don't have to do idol worship. Na
tasya pratima asti. Of that God there is
no pratima. There is no idol. There is
no image. There is no photograph.
There's no sculpture.
And I have had dialogues
with pundits of Hinduism, with
Shankaracharyas. Many.
And I've quoted this. No Shankaracharya
told me, "Brother Zakir, you're wrong."
No one.
I had a dialogue with Sri Sri Ravi
Shankar
on 21st of January. Supposed to be the
most popular spiritual guru, Art of
Living.
I told him the best book on Art of
Living
is the Glorious Quran.
I asked him to join our club of Art of
Living. We have 1.3 billion members.
1.3 billion members. I gave him an
invitation.
If If follows the scriptures, he's
supposed to be a scholar of the Vedas.
He should come to this. Similarly,
sister, when I say that all the other
scriptures, even if you agree with the
word of God, by the passage of time they
have been changed. Swami Vivekananda
says that 99% of the Vedas have been
lost. Whatever 1% we have, we have to
follow it strictly. Strictly means
believe in the Rishi also.
So, if you follow it strictly, you'll
have to believe in Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam.
Have to believe in the Quran.
And
give you an invitation, sister,
to come to this religion of peace,
so that you can come closer to Almighty
God.
Question from this mic here, please.
It's a great opportunity for this August
evening to have a a valuable, immortal,
and moral, and religious, spiritual
lecture. We are all impressed by your
way of telling, which is changes the
person's attitude.
My highest regard, my name is Ramdas.
I'm personal officer from Electricity
Board.
So, I got highest regard for Islam.
Being a Hindu, I got a highest Islam. I
agree with you. Just now you said
that Hinduism never speaks of idol
worship. It's unfortunate Hinduism are
being misguided by egoistic thoughts of
the religious so-called leaders.
They are deliberately misleading the
people.
In the same Hindus, they say 90% of the
Hindus are being misguided saying that
idol worship. Idol worship Vedas,
Upanishads never speaks about idol
worship. It is only the rule.
The rule is the criteria. Rule Khuda ki
inayat hai.
Wo rule ko
Christianity may soul kehte hang Islam
may rule Hindus may Atma
is very unfortunate the egoistic
attitude of the take it off of all
religious whether is a Muslim
Christianity or Hindus they are the
egoistic fellows
who misguide the humanity people in
general all over the world. Now question
my question before you my beloved a
learned intellectual person is at the
just now Mr. Dewan of the Delhi has
rightly pointed out that Islam is a
glorious past at every stage but
unfortunately Islam has come to the
laughable stock in the present days of
the world. The reason is
the take it off of the Muslims leaders
like Hindu leaders
they are making Rohan equal but Johnny
may and they just a G day hey Yeah they
get the uncle called Kodak in Nuri Nuri
hey but in sun and the monkey G raha hey
guy yes about both of the hey key sewage
egg hey how about good Muslim knee a
panic good Muslim knee a egg Muslim
Hindu by egg Muslim and ordered to me
home data ordered G 16 hey to come home
job job home blood I got DD egg Hindu or
Muslim and ordered to get any one John
but gay hey guy hey what's up guy hey
key yeah hey yeah Hindu yeah Muslim and
ordered to you Islam and get that's the
first question please try to
I am analyzing my question secondly who
didn't you say no but Johnny hey to Nuri
Dilki do a duty I made a beta made a
John but Johnny hey made a beta yeah
past you or past you is the B past you
is the blood so Muslim and ordered to
whiskey ordered to
Nuri near the
to his school but kiss to say in sun and
keep a lady to say in sun egg Muslim and
so no big saga beta go home tell me what
do you know
mother
Islamic
This is the first one.
It's a good in Islam. charity help
winning fellow being
Islamic
which no
We agree for
It's a very nice virtues. Unfortunately,
there's no implementation in the real
life. So, Mr. Dewan said the madrasas to
be transparent. Let the Hindus might be
needed Islamic
Islamic
Christianity egoism They want to supreme
powers. They want to curtail the Islam.
There is a egoistic attitude of
Christianity. Hinduism They want for the
existence.
So, these are all the take it out. They
are not finding what is rule. rule for
that key
Islamic on Bible may
So, this
So, Islamic
Islamic
rule for my butt
Islamic World is a religion World is a
religion of Muhammad. Islamic This is my
first question. Second question. Second
question. And this is my first question.
Islamic Islamic Second question is
Islamic
a bullying
Hinduism in here
Hinduism
Islamic
Christianity
that man could
No, man man cannot give birth to a
child. It is a mother. It is a lady
which gives birth to The world starts as
we live.
So, all
all uh doomsday in Christianity.
Oh, this is the second question. Can
Islam
do doomsday
doomsday meaning Can Islam
I will answer a question, brother. You
have asked a question.
I've got your question, brother.
Thank you for your that you will give I
am writing a book.
I am writing to the a question to the
world. All religions
Why this was Thank you, brother, for a
very short speech.
And thank you for the good words
you spoke about me and about Islam. As
far as I am concerned all praise are due
to Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala alone. You
called me a scholar. You called me a
knowledgeable person. I am just a
student. I consider myself to be a
student on Islam and comparative
religion.
You posed two questions, one on Drew and
then on women. Before that, you made
certain statement. You said that most of
the religious take it out are causing
problems.
Majority, I do agree with you. Then you
also went and said that Islam is being
maligned
because the religious leaders of Islam
they
are causing a bad name for Islam. As far
as religious leaders of the other
communities
they prevent
their followers to read the scripture
and do research.
As far as Islam is concerned as a whole
I don't blame the religious scholars of
Islam, the religious leaders.
There are a few black sheep. Very few.
There are a very small number
of so-called religious scholars who are
misleading, but they are a very small
percentage.
The media picks them up and portrays as
though every Islamic religious scholar
is like that. Therefore, as far as
Islamic religious scholars are
concerned, ulama's are concerned, we
love them, we respect them. There are a
few people, a very small percentage
who do take advantage and misguide the
people, but as a whole
as a whole, alhamdulillah
they speak the good things. They talk
about the religion. We love them, we
respect them. In contrast to other
religions most of the other religious
leaders
of the other religions, they don't do
that. They prevent
the followers from reading the
scriptures. Like you rightly said,
Hinduism condemned idol worship, etc.,
but more than 90% are doing idol worship
because they don't want their followers
to read the scriptures.
Coming to your question
you said
that
if a Hindu
give a blood to a Muslim
the Muslim's life is saved.
Main thing is rohani.
So, where is the mazhab?
Does the person become a Hindu? Or if a
Muslim gives a blood to a Hindu, does he
become a Muslim?
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Maidah,
chapter number five, verse number 32. If
anyone
saves any other human being
if any person, whether Muslim or
non-Muslim, saves any other human being,
whether Muslim or non-Muslim, it is as
though he has saved the whole of
humanity.
So, if any human being gives a blood to
any other human being and saves a life,
whether Muslim gives to a Hindu or a
Hindu gives to a Muslim, that person has
saved the whole of humanity.
The ayat further says, "If anyone kills
any other human being
unless it be for murder or for creating
corruption in the land, it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity."
But, saving a life of a human being is
very good.
It's a good deed, very high deed, but
the earlier question posed was
why has God created us?
I told you earlier Allah says in Surah
Mulk, chapter number 67, verse number
two.
It is Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds. Saving someone's life is a very
great deed.
But, saving someone's akhirah, next
life, is a bigger deed.
That's the reason I
I was a doctor.
Supposed to be the best profession.
Saving human life. I chose to be a
doctor
because I thought it was the most
noblest profession. It is.
But,
I found a nobler profession. Allah says
in Surah Fussilat, chapter number 41,
verse number 33. Who is better in speech
than one who invites people to the way
of their Lord
who does righteous deeds and says that I
am the one who submit my will to
Almighty God. So, I changed from being a
doctor of a body to a doctor of a soul.
Which is a better profession? So, giving
someone
blood and saving his life is good, but
giving someone the truth and saving his
akhira is better.
So much